[Applause]
okay so look the lakers won bro
the lakers won dominating fashion
game six was dominating game five jimmy
butler did his thing again
oh beautiful and then game six the
lakers were just not having it
on not having it well i'm not having it
brian said i'm locking up jimmy the
whole game yep
they did their [ __ ] thing um
after lebron and lakers win lebron is
being interviewed by
rachel nichols or whoever it is and
he says i want my respect i want my damn
respect i want my damn respect too
yeah but he really just said respect
everybody else so he's just so he can
say that anybody give a [ __ ] about
respect and what's
bob palinkum get the [ __ ] out of here
not rob lowe
that's all you are to me is not blah
blah blah blah dude [ __ ] out of here
nobody respect you
lebron want his damn respect now why do
you think he said that
i think he wants to be the goat i don't
think he's there yet
he's not do you believe that he believes
he
is and then how is he justifying that to
himself
so in other words you're lebron james
you believe you're the goat
you don't have six rings how are you
justifying you're better than jordan
with what you've done i think you always
and whatever you do you have to believe
you are a little better than you really
are
whatever what do you think he's doing i
think i never had a phil jackson as a
coach i never had a great coach gotcha i
don't even know if i've ever he's ever
had a good coach spoelstra early in his
career but spoelstra wasn't what he is
now
yeah then uh he thinks i never had
scottie pippen i had some good teammates
but now i finally got my pippin dwayne
wade was really good that first year
then when we finally won the
championship starting then he would get
hurt every playoffs
okay i think he thinks i was around in f
to ask cleveland for years of the
organization [ __ ] up everything
so and i came back against arguably the
greatest team ever seventy three and
nine
everyone fair to say your argument is
he thinks he did more with less yes well
said
okay cut that down way better than i did
i did what you usually do no no
no doubt sick dude no synergy yeah so uh
it's humbling
isn't it yeah i hate it when you do that
[ __ ] to me even though i love like i'd
be saying the longest rant and you're
just like yeah a plus b
did i just do math with letters
i thought i killed it two and then he
was like more worth less i was like
he did more with less so your point is
more with less which i think is a great
argument i think there's also something
to say
to be said with him doing with three
different organizations
i think people sleep on that every new
organization you go to you gotta build a
new team
granted the bulls built two teams
technically right right
but it's the same organization and the
same key players
lebron had to go do this again in
cleveland
build the whole team around him again
with the lakers yeah
we could say it's easy because you're
lebron everybody wants to play with you
but it's not that easy
right getting everybody to have the same
chemistry establishing the culture
getting a coach that's going to run the
culture that you want to have there
yeah it's not like the lakers have
culture no right the lakers doesn't have
culture l.a doesn't have culture
right the the lakers were kobe and then
when kobe left there was just a giant
void
yeah to be filled right yeah so
i think that's a really interesting
argument and i think that he and
especially with the 3-1 [ __ ]
he might go no i don't think jordan
could do that and i would agree because
i don't think jordan would let himself
go down
3-1 right but that being said
there are there is a solid argument for
his goat
ship if you will
i don't think he's there nope i think
he's actually
two more rings away yeah
in my opinion i think in order to be
spoken about with jordan you need the
six
but i think as far as our generation
goes
he's number two and it's not close yeah
i think there used to be close number
twos for our generation we didn't see
wilt yeah we didn't see bill russell
right we didn't see those [ __ ]
but we didn't see kareem no
we didn't even see magic really didn't
see magic or bird really or bird
yeah but we saw kobe we saw
jordan and we saw lebron and i think
that we can all unanimously say
number two yeah is lebron yeah
and if that wasn't solidified before
within our generation again not the old
heads within our generation
i think this solidifies it yeah do you
think so
yeah and um i think if you have to
go public and say give me my respect
that makes you number two jordan never
had to tell anybody
it was given that is true earned
like he was crowned the best so you got
to go out there and tell [ __ ]
then
united but you know what's interesting
now is that
jordan was equally upset at the
disrespect
of not getting mvp that final year
remember they gave it to carl malone
yeah
was it his fifth championship or a sixth
game he also didn't get it
i think yeah so he got like five mvps
total or something like that
and six championships but he was upset
that carl malone got it and not him yep
as he should have been as he should have
been of course just like lebron this
year was upset
that giannis got it i think it was a six
i think they kept talking about in last
dance like
oh he was pissed so they both have that
chip
but jordan goes about it differently
yeah lebron probably has that chip
because he knows that there are more
uh things that can be criticized jordan
has left very few
things to criticize right jordan's like
yo anytime i go to the dance i win that
[ __ ]
yeah lebron has gone to the dance and
not one so he knows there's always going
to be
something to be said about him even
though he went
more times than jordan yes
10 trips to the finals is crazy you yo
what's his face said it best
um i forget exactly oh jimmy butler said
it best he goes
if you want to go to the nba
championship the road is going to lead
through or to a lebron james team yeah
he's the first player in nba history to
win
three finals mpps with or three finals
mvps
teams yeah we all thought it was gonna
be kawhi this year and we all just kind
of counted out lebron i did
i thought they have no depth behind mnad
and i think one la went out and
also when milwaukee went out it was just
like that's it it's done
it's done how many years and i want to i
want to talk a lot about
uh jimmy butler because he just had this
amazing bubble but like
let's talk about how many more years of
championship lebron we have lebron put
the team on his back
yeah like don't get me wrong a.d played
exceptionally he was huge he was
defensively huge defensively huge
especially his paint presence massive
but lebron locking up jimmy butler and
just saying game six it's over yo
if let's not forget game five lebron
played his look
lebron was like we going home yeah and
he passed up the shot to danny green
which is what lebron always
i knew before during the timeout i said
i lebron is going to
get doubled pass out the guy's going to
miss a shot whoever he passes to
because lebron will always make the
right basketball play
and sometimes the right basketball play
is the right is the wrong game ending
play because you want that shot taken by
the best player
but the right basketball play is to pass
that off
to the guy that you literally signed to
be your wide open three-point shooter
his only reason for being on the lakers
is to knock down open threes and play
defense he's a good defender as well
i feel like
i feel like lebron is
yeah i think it's number two i think
it's number two if braun didn't go off
game five in game six he might not have
even got the mvp
because ad had a better stat line for
the first three games um
i wonder if that's a little motivation
going off game five game six
won him the mvp because stat line wise
he wouldn't have had it so how long do
we have left for peak championship
lebron that's where we were
truthfully he's locked up he's an
abnormal like he's
abnormal his [ __ ] body is crazy he
can keep going
like i can see three maybe
four strong ones you're a wild boy for
that son his body
his body's crazy here's the difference i
think he
there will be at least one year where
he's not quite peak lebron but we don't
notice because a.d is still going to
keep getting better
and i think that will carry lebron a
little bit i'm with i'm with akash on
this i think you got one more year
of lebron can carry the team and then i
think you have
two more years after that of lebron
being a number two
or three option so he can play this
point forward position
but the game is really flowing through
a.d kind of similar to how the heat were
where there were times where dwyane wade
was the number one on that team
yeah that first year in particular but
that i think that's why that didn't work
out the first year and then dwayne
went to him was like you got to be the
guy right right i think ad is good
enough where he can be that
yeah i think lebron is actually his
natural position is to defer yeah like
he takes on the
offensive load because he has to but if
it was up to him
i think that he would slash and dish and
really get other people involved
and i think if he's going to get two
more rings
it's one with him leading and then
there's another one with
someone else leading maybe ad and
letting and i think he's situated
perfectly to do it because a.d could
still continue to blossom
and i think 80 likes lebron is like a
mentor i think that's what they were
talking about in the post games like
they've helped he's helped eddie get to
another level
yeah 100 yes my dear you don't think
that him playing in the bubble
like this year did any difference to him
winning the championship so i want to
talk about that real quick with the
bubble that's a really good point
people say that there's an asterisk on
the bubble championship some people say
no player says that players think that
this one is harder
yeah because there's nothing that you
could say that gives you an advantage
like if you have home court advantage
you have amazing home court it's really
hard to play there
you could go well yeah we don't have
home court advantage so game seven was
in golden state and of course we're
gonna lose in golden state
nobody has home court advantage yeah
everybody's rested this is as fair as it
could possibly be
everybody's eating the same food
nobody's getting poisoned by
some random restaurant like sending
pizzas to jordan's place
literally everybody had the exact same
uh what is it called um like pregame
this is as
level as the playing field yeah 100
level playing field you might never
experience this again unless they do
another bubble
so to say that this is in some you know
way shape or form unfair is completely
[ __ ] it is the most fair it's ever
been
this is the most like jordan i think
he's ever been because i think there's
the only people who could win the
championship in this bubble
is that type of killer jordan kobe
lebron
i would have said kawhi but i think the
clippers around him couldn't do it
but it is [ __ ] everything i am
completely focused on winning a
championship
i don't care how how crazy the world is
around me this is the goal and we're all
coming i don't give a [ __ ] we're all
getting there
and that's kind of what lebron did
focus-wise i thought he was like hey
guys this is where we're going
[ __ ] everything we're having a season he
was always a guy that's like we're
having a season patrick beverly said
lebron wants to play so we're going to
play that's what jordan would have done
that's what kobe would have done
the killers of the killers are coming
out of this panel yeah he did look like
a killer man
he looked like it in game five when they
lost and he looked like in game six
when it was like when he was locking up
jimmy the whole [ __ ] time
yeah it is it is i don't think you can
put an asterisk on at all
um how's your question maybe not an
asterisk but something has to go like
you have to just acknowledge that was
the bubble season yeah yeah it's
different like they had a rest
throughout the mid-season like maybe his
body wouldn't have held up
had they had that big rest so it's right
it does change something
yeah you're right we all got to adjust
to everything and i think he adjusted
the best and that's
a testament to him i think what alex is
saying is like you can acknowledge that
there are
different variables here and then a
regular season so maybe the asterisk
doesn't mean it was easier but you got
to put the asterisk yeah exactly
fair enough yeah higher enough it was a
level playing field you're saying
but just different yeah yeah i'm with
you on that let me ask you a game five
questions
lebron does and maybe i'm biased for
sure it's quite possible lebron always
passes out at the end of a game
in my mind that almost never works out i
can think of jordan passing it out maybe
because we're always shocked when he
does it
and steve karnachana down john paxton
knocking it down in my mind every time i
think of lebron drawing the double and
passing it out at the end of the game
the guy misses
the closest i came it came i think was
george hill
against golden satan game one where he
like got fouled and then missed one of
the free throws to tie up the game
what about what about with kyrie
for the game winner kyrie i think just
dribbled it up right
no i think he got it on the wing didn't
maybe
remember maybe but braun had no choice
because
if he tries to force up a shot with a
double team and you have a wide open
danny green and then a bronze misses
everybody's saying you're an idiot
because you have a wide open danny green
yeah so it's like he he was between a
rock and a hard place like he made he
made the right he made the right
basketball
and they and he bailed danny green out
by winning game six and you know that
will be complete nobody's even talking
about it yeah 100.